votre souffle dans cette pharmacie tous
les clients règlent par carte bancaire
aucun distributeur à proximité depuis
plus de 15 ans le plus proche est à 10
minutes de voiture quand on fait ce cet
aller retour on va à la pharmacie où on
fait des courses en même temps donc pour
ne pas faire le voyage pour juste pour
ça tant qu'on a nos possibilités
personnel n'y a pas de souci mais sinon
c'est vrai que pour les gens qui
habitent la campagne qui n'ont pas
forcément de véhicules
donc pour eux ils sont quand même perdu
ici 2500 habitants sont concernées par
cette désertification bancaire pour les
élus c'est un véritable casse tête bien
souvent les banques elles ne veulent pas
suivre parce que pour elle c'est un coût
déjà très important de pouvoir mettre un
distributeur et il ya le problème aussi
bas de la sécurité pour remplir donc les
distributeurs dans les villages voisins
on est en quête de solutions vous avez
la carte mastercard dedans vous allez
ensuite faire une inscription auprès de
sept bornes où vous pouvez scanner votre
pièce d'identité
et vous renseigner toutes les
informations devant leur une vingtaine
de points de retrait comme celui ci sont
implantées dans le département mais il
ne rencontre pas le succès attendu par
cette buraliste
depuis la prise du côté de beaucoup de
gens payent maintenant par carte bleue
même maintenant pour une baguette
c'est aussi quand même un coût pour le
commerçant donc c'est vrai qu'avoir un
distributeur d'espèces dans le village
ça permettrait d'avoir quand même moins
de moins de frais ces dix dernières
années
55 agences bancaires auraient disparu
dans le loiret